welcome back well if you're wondering
what the difference between Body
Sculpting and liposuction is well fast
Fit Body Sculpting the sponsors of this
segment can help break it all down and
joining us now is our friend Doug Zuko
thanks for coming back Doug great thank
you for having me so before we get into
some before and afters I know you have a
special story to share today but let's
just break it down for anyone who
doesn't know what your services are and
how they differ from traditional
liposuction well liposuction is actually
removing fat cells and that sounds
fantastic but there's a lot of side
effects and a lot of danger right
and basically we don't have to do that
we don't have to kill our fat cells we
just need to shrink them and that's
exactly what we do at fast fit so it
doesn't sound
too dangerous at all it's very healthy
and I always wonder kind of the recovery
time what should someone prepare for if
they come receive a treatment with fast
fit there's absolutely no recovery time
because we're not doing anything
invasive at all and you have to remember
when you remove fat cells people don't
know this but you're actually removing
stem cells and you don't want to do that
wow okay I'm already learning so much in
our first minute of talking here and who
would be the ideal client let's say that
should be eligible for something like
this actually it's anybody we've done it
people from the age eight right children
really to 94. wow so anyone can come in
whether an athlete whether you're an
older person whatever so we have some
fun photos here let's talk about
Jeanette though share a little bit about
Jeanette's story with us real quick
Jeanette 77 years old down 17 and a half
pounds of fat in 90 days and the funny
part about Jeanette's story her husband
owns a weight loss center really how did
he take all of that but
clients like of all
and what is it like for you to see how
happy they are after receiving a
treatment well it's amazing when people
look better and feel better right but
for older people it's life-changing
absolute life change they're able to do
things they haven't been able to do for
a very long time and what about sagging
skin or anything afterwards you have to
worry about that or what do you guys do
for that no saggy skinners fast food
never wow not only helps moisturize the
skin from the inside out but also builds
collagen the skin so it helps get rid of
fine lines and wrinkles all of that to
avoid all of that and I think we're
looking at Jane here what's Jane's story
Jane's 60 years old lost 30 and a half
pounds of pure fat looking beautiful oh
my gosh so all age groups I didn't even
know that you could work on children too
so it's safe for everybody safe forever
safe enough for children wow so if
people want to come in they want to
learn a little bit more about what you
do do you offer consultations or how
does that work absolutely 1-800 fastfit
come on and just learn about what we do
I'm going to be doing consultations
personally this week also giving
everybody a Rowdy towel for the golden
knights yes I was just going to say
you're here cheering on the golden
knights and you
and care of right come in this week
learn about what we do and get a rally
cow too well Doug thank you so much
for breaking this all down really seeing
those pictures side by side helps put
into perspective everything that you do
you do so thank you to facet Body
Sculpting for sponsoring the segment you
can call 1-800 fast fit or visit fast
dot fit and they have a special offer
the first 20 callers can get up to 60
off their services JC over to you